dans notre séquence ping pong nous
parlons cinéma avec franck dubosc pour
le film camping 2 fabien oteniente un
film dans lequel du [ __ ] où vous verrez
un chirac
on verra lequel et dans lequel il est co
scénariste que dire de ce film dont j'ai
dit que vous étiez coscénariste pas
pourquoi parce que vous avez vous une
expérience du camping crois que j'ai
fait du camping jusqu'à l'âge de 36 ans
et je suis allé rejoindre j'ai fait du
camping petit gamin adolescents et je
suis allé rejoindre mes parents jusqu'à
l'âge de 36 ans à 36 ans mais par moment
arrêter d'en faire parce que mon père
est tombé malade et puis et puis ensuite
il est mort donc ils ont complètement
arrêté d'en faire forcément
et là j'ai pu y aller j'ai pu retrouver
pu retrouver l'occasion de l'acjar d'y
retourner parce que c'était vraiment un
prétexte à les rejoindre
voilà donc ce qui veut dire que ce film
a beaucoup de caractère autobiographique
qui s'est nourri de votre expérience
et comme vous venez de dire
particulièrement de la relation avec
votre père et de la façon que vous
alliez de faire du camping avec lui ce
qui est autobiographique dans le film
s'est fait surtout l'humeur le l'amour
des gens que j'ai rencontrés dans pas
dans les campings parce que ça me fait
toujours drôle de dire dans le camping
on a l'impression que c'est un lieu très
particulier les campeurs une espèce de
deux comme ça dans deux en vacances
des gens bien des gens book et j'avais
envie de leur rendre hommage le film
voilà on va voir ce qu'il en est cet
hommage alors on est au début du mois
d'août c'est l'arrivée donc camping
toujours un moment très particulier
parce que c'est un habitué le début des
vacances alors on va je crois le mieux
pour que les gens se fassent une idée
s'est élancée la bande annonce
après quoi on lancera la critique à
laquelle vous répondrais y accolant son
mandat mais on n'est pas en panne elle
attend le coucher du soleil à l'inversé
si on en fait on est où là s'il vous
plaît entre arcachon et le boulot vous
n'avez qu'à lire camping des flots bleus
effet pourquoi vous n'achetez pas une
maison ici notre balance que je vais
devenir là tout le temps puisque ça fait
30 ans menée si tous les ans mais c'est
pas prêt las on veut on peut aller
ailleurs c'est ça le campi action
c'est pour moi tu t'appelles cher à toi
ah oui chirac
patrick chirac beauté change pas de nom
de rue c'est moi qui changerait on
n'attend pas patrick donc maintenant
venons en à la critique de christophe
château à la ola lancée
bonjour franck dubosc bonjour jusque là
ce garçon est plutôt très très bien vous
couvrant seulement donc on est ici pour
parler de camping donc en camping fait
aussi partie de cette catégorie de films
qui prend en fait une caste enfin qui
cible une caste pour l'extrapoler façon
film comme
jet set utiliser la bourgeoisie les
nantis et c'est là où la vérité si je
mens la communauté juive ou là où il n'a
pas tort je sais si on prend jet set
m la vérité si je mens au milieu est un
petit peu bizarre mais si on prend jet
set oui c'est un film sur on va dire un
milieu social web on peut pas mentir là
dessus elle est le camping est un autre
milieu social qui est si moi je suis
allé demander à fabien otteniente de
faire un film qui se passe dans un
camping c'est que je savais que s'il
avait décrit un film qui se passait dans
la jet set il est allé là les trouvais
ça croustillant d'aller dans un autre un
autre milieu un autre monde l'espagne
cast est ce qu'il ya c'est que des fois
derrière il ya de vraies idées une vraie
recherche et c'est pas toujours le cas
là on sent chez lui une vraie volonté de
de réhabiliter l'image du campeur
l'image un peu comme une con à 2
du compère enfin durable alors est-ce
qu'il fallait réhabiliter l'image du
campement mais d'abord pour réhabiliter
quelqu un quelque chose il faut que
cette personne était et était exclu
si ma maman qui est une ancienne
campeuse où mon papa entendez ça ils
seraient gênées de penser qu'on puisse
avoir à l'instant l'idée de les
réhabiliter
parce que tout à coup elle se dira m et
donc ça pendant 40 ans où je suis allé
en vacances dans un camping j'ai fait
quelque chose de délicieux voilà c'est
pour ça aussi que le film est
intéressant
enfin après on aime ou on n'aime pas
mais c'est que le film est intéressant
c'est que ça parle de gens d'une france
moyenne on sait plus les morisques honda
dire prolétaires france moyenne dit
l'ailier qu'on veut moi je dis du
français ordinaires français mon père ma
mère qui sont les gens ni mieux que les
autres ni moins bien et qui sont des
jambes donc les réhabiliter non par les
deux oui et parler d'eux en bien
bah ouais je suis pas envie de kamurochô
machad avec amour sont les vedettes du
film on va quand même pas se mettre à
les rendre méchant donc ça a un côté un
peu démago aussi de montrer toujours
les petites gens entre guillemets sous
leur meilleur jour donc là et il a une
idée des campeurs et du camping qui est
celle qu'on donne dans l'est dans les
reportages à la télévision et les
reportages à la télévision choisissent
des campings qui sont accole souvent
c'est le camping de port-grimaud camping
de port grimaud parce que port grimaud
est à côté de saint-tropez et on veut
voir des campeurs allez rêver devant les
riches oui et là on nous demande des
mots là oui là il a raison mais ça
marronniers ça c'est vrai qu'on le
revoit chaque mais voilà ça on le sait
et nous on a voulu éviter ça se rajoute
à ça le fait que camping part avec un
handicap énorme un handicap
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas aujourd'hui
faire un film avec des vacanciers en
maillot de bain et sans penser
instantanément aux bronzés alors deux
choses premièrement c'est pas un
handicap d'être un film qui serait dans
la lignée des bronzés et ce jeune homme
est en train d'oublier qu'il ya eu
l'hôtel de la plage à kehl on est moins
prétentieux que ça on n'a pas envie du
succès des bronzés on a envie de plus
pas de ressembler mais de l'humeur de
l'hôtel de la plage
si on avait voulu faire les bronzés on
se serait on aurait fait une caricature
beaucoup plus forte
les campeurs ou avec de la vanne là on a
fait un film qu'elle beaucoup plus
d'émotions que j'adore je suis un fan
forcément les bronzés à des bronzés deux
très bien aussi
camping est pas vraiment n'en est pas un
film dans cette lignée là j'ai presque
envie de dire hélas hélas jeu pourquoi
pas c'est un autre film serait un autre
film au final à trop en faire à trop
vouloir police et ses personnages
les mettre tous sur un pied d'égalité où
ils sont tous d'une vente il y est
extrême
ces voix là bas ça n'a plus aucun relief
non ça ne parle pas dans le sens inverse
de ce qu'ils voulaient faire sa part
dans le sens inverse de ce qu'ils
voulaient voir ces salles etc souligné
lors le goût de leur côté france
profonde et un peu
venez quoi donc ce que si je comprends
bien le fait qu'il soit gentil souligner
le fait qu'ils soient de la france
profonde et benêt et bene non non ça va
pas parce que balawi la étape sur mon
père ne l'a en fait dans ce film moi
j'ai tellement voulu montrer la
gentillesse et le mont mon père est
parti dans gta vendent avant que de voir
ce film j'ai persuadé que je sais ce que
je ne savais et de son statut social et
ce film c'est un petit peu pour lui
montrer que bach que j'avais pas du tout
monte et que je trouvais que ces gens
qui m'a fait rencontrer lui la maman mes
amis de camping le vrai jacques qui
existent basse et les gens que j'ai aimé
et il était peut-être sans relief comme
il le dit mais était gentil et moi ça
c'est un bon relief d'être gentil et
puis vous savez moi j'ai vu mon père
pendant onze mois de l'année tous les
ans gris sombre par les tracas de la vie
quotidienne qui était pas facile
le chômage la maladie plein de choses
vraiment vraiment pas facile et quand
ils arrivèrent au camping et bah ce même
monsieur ketting gris dans le reste de
l'année
il avait un grand sourire comme ça et
redevenait gentil et sans relief parce
que son relief
il avait 11 mois de l'année pour la voir
j'ai fait du contenu et légumes par an
je comprends voilà mais souvent les gens
qui ont fait du camping comprennent plus
on note aussi une un manque d'audace
assez évident on ne serait ce qu'à
regarder lequel signe
un manque d'audace sur le casting
mathilde seigner en campeuse alors
revenons à une saignée dans une rolls
une campeuse claude brasseur qu'à
l'habitude de jeu les bourgeois
n'enrôlent d'un campeur gérard lanvin
dans le rôle d'un bourgeois mais pour
l'instant je parlerai de nas justement
car c'est assez facile de prendre
mathilde seigner camp
qui est à tout moment idéal qu'on
cherche et ne
un personnage de femme tout en verve
alors juste pour lui répondre parce que
c'est le sait peut-être pas mathilde
seigner n'est pas le personnage idéal
quand on cherche une personne en verve
c'est qu'on a écrit le rôle pour
mathilde seigner c'est complètement
différent il ya aucune surprise de ce
côté là et c'est à l'image aussi du
reste du film
ça c'est un bon point qui est pas de
surprise dans le film parce que les gens
ont envie de le voir
ils sont contents différence qu'ils
voulaient voir le seul qui est à la
limite se se démarque un peu de ça
justement c'est vous quand même a donc
il faut bien rendre à césar qui est
justement vous êtes vous jouez du
personnage de séducteur que vous aimez
bien interpréter d'habitude mais en même
temps derrière il ya aussi une autre
enfin vous laisse filtrer une petite
sensibilité et qui apporte beaucoup à
votre personnage quoi donc c'est déjà ça
de gagner quoi
oui tout de suite si le personnage
principal du film
et bien c'est déjà ça de gagné
effectivement personnages du film co
scénariste et à bord puis je trouve ça
très intéressant mais aussi des
critiques je ne suis pas vexé par les
critiques parce que je comprends aussi
la vie de chacun ils l'expliquent c'est
bien de deux je trouve ça très très bien
me dire à quelqu'un que qu'on n'a pas
aimé quelque chose et puis de dire
pourquoi
voilà nous parlions avec franck dubosc
de camping de fabien oteniente avec
toute la distribution dont nous avons
parlé maintenant pour vous faire une
idée
c'est simple vous allez en salle et vous
nous direz franck dubosc merci au revoir
merci beaucoup
[Musique]